hey this interview is brought to you by
our good Folks at Imperial extractions
ladies and gentlemen now check this out
if you want a free two G pre-roll
delivered right to your door they got
you go get a free 2 G thca Diamond
infused pre-roll with any order right
now we're talking about 1 and half grams
of top shell flour and a half a gram of
pure thca diamonds Imperial extraction.
comom promo code bootleg and you're
going to get this for free delivered
right to your door let's let's get to
the
interview what's your favorite Disney
movie of all
time um The Little Vampire the little oh
you talking about um I don't know the
little vampire Transylvania it's kind of
old it's about the kids I think he stays
in Switzerland or some [__] in the
little it's a Disney movie I watched it
on Disney when I was little oh
[__] so we're like far apart in age well
not too far 12 years I don't age myself
too much but when I was growing up it
was Lion King Aladdin Toy
Story those were the ones wait so Toy
Story that old oh yeah thanks buddy damn
oh I'm sorry I apologize man no
disrespect no it's all good I'm old as
[__] I get it I'm washed man yeah
twister is that old the first one at
least I hope so how's the bread whatever
is so do you want to you want to wear
the
hat the first Toy Story came out
probably when I was like I want to say
like 8 years old maybe nine so it's
definitely old school but I don't
know
um you got it go put it on man show
everybody my [__] up hair you been a
bully he's
fine babies are going to baby man for
you man talk about fatherhood and how uh
you know
obviously you do have a lot of children
and and uh you know I've been around you
to see in a short amount of time that
you're a great father how important is
fatherhood to you
man not really big on it to be
honest what do you mean by that you're
not big on it like you're I mean you're
a family man I'm here with you I see
it yeah but I'm only I I'm only like in
here cuz you here oh well I don't
believe you it's a crazy topic cuz I'm
not the type like the sugar coat
nothing but I'm four walls all
day every day when you say four walls
you mean locked in yeah just HED in on
the music
recording you can take the hat I don't
mind we B we bed a lot but mostly L
inside working
no no matter if I'm watching TV I'm just
sitting there all day
um stuck inside just one room I don't
really travel this house like that so
even in your own home you'll be stuck in
one room man I don't know like he wants
the Hat he can take the Hat Jason let
him take the Hat he wants it you can
have it um so even at home you I mean
obviously we're in a beautiful house
right now you beautiful home you'll
still kind of just stick to one room in
the house yeah what do you think
um why is that you think
man I don't know
I I would say I'm like I I I wouldn't
say I'm going through a lot I'm
just
me do you find
yourself you know I've heard you refer
to the music as as therapy I am going to
need this hat actually cuz this is this
is bright
um do you feel
like being alone in your thoughts is a
form of therapy for
you it's kind of my way stand
saying being by yourself being secluded
relaxing is it watching TV is it writing
is it I don't do no writing um
yeah watching TV up in a video
game what
is your goto movie TV show like what
about TV shows like what are you
watching what are you binge watching
what's young boy binge
watching I'm boring so what do you watch
man but old [__] what's old to you cuz
what's old you might be like um I watch
the
AOS greatest maybe top two show ever
uh I watch The Godfather is back to back
all three mhm third one's the worst one
right
yeah I think it's like one it's kind of
the best to see is growth but you learn
that like it kind of give you the
thought of that's why you need to stay
dangerous that's true that's why that's
why you need to stay dangerous um so you
love
Sopranos yeah what about breaking bad
did you ever watch Breaking Bad oh yeah
I watched that with my wife um a couple
episodes probably yeah couple episodes I
like it breaking bad's crazy the wire is
another one if you love Sopranos I
watched the wire too did you finish it
yeah I pra it I watched it twice the
whole like season me too I just
rewatched it when the pandemic first
started I showed my wife and it made me
realize like I don't know it just got
better the second watch like Omar little
has got to be one of the greatest uh
like TV characters ever I who was your
favorite character on The
Wire Bodie BOD Man the story of BOD Man
shout out to Bodie and he lasted so long
in the show too yeah he just a cat just
cut at the right time he didn't man
that's
real you should I feel like somebody
should do it could be you anybody should
do a song from the perspective of
bod like I think that would be crazy cuz
yeah man bod was he like he hung around
he survived for so long in that show he
had it hard too [__] over on bad for
sure that's dope man so the wire is my
favorite show of all time what about uh
video games what are you playing right
now watch dogs um love Watch Dogs R de
and Madden
Red Dead Redemption is amazing um we
were talking earlier about it when you
were on your horse but if you're on
Madden what's your what's what Squad are
you picking this year I be R I've been
running with the dolphins a lot Tyreek
Tyreek Hill is a cheat code right yeah
just they man that team is like strictly
speed on offense my son murders me with
Ty kill every single time he kind of
hard to guard he's like the wide
receiver Mike so back in the day Mike
Vic when he was in
Madden Mike Vic was kind of the cheat
cod in Madden what's up
man and um I feel like Tyreek Hill this
year is the cheat code uhhuh get high
five
no high
five yeah man I miss having a
one-year-old my son's 18 my son just
turned 18 I got a little grown ass yeah
that's his favorite
word yeah yeah yeah yeah pound it there
we go y you're learning your words you
you want the Hat again you can have for
a sec it's bright though hey what up
y'all I'm excited cuz I'm going to be
flying to Tampa to DJ the odd Sox
holiday party next week and of course as
y'all know odd Soxs are OG sponsors our
family the most comfortable socks in the
world want to give much love to odd Soxs
for always holding us down at the bleake
podcast now it is the holiday season
there ain't nothing like getting you a
pair of Odd Socks for your loved one
getting some underwear getting a hat
whatever you're into they got it oddsock
official.com promo code bootleg save 20%
off 20% off at check out right now all
the licenses WWE uh I mean
Hooters oh some hooters underwear let's
take a peek at these huh bunch of
[__] owls all over here there we go M
I like it what about Chucky ain't
nothing like some Chucky socks during
the Christmas you know hey whatever
you're into they got it oddsocks
official.com use the promo code bootleg
right now save 20% off uh and enjoy the
most comfortable socks in the world also
want to give a shout out to our family
over there King pom now that's to think
about King
pom what I love about King pom no
tobacco no nicotine we're talking about
straight natural Leaf organic Leaf all
right and and and the cool thing is they
got these tpping infused tips
when I tell you they're turpy and
Infused I mean it like I love these ones
shout out to uh Sugar Shane sugar Shan
[__] I almost [__] his name up uh
sugar Shan Ali from Phoenix uh he's got
his honey orange here how it works you
load that thing up with your cannabis
flow you got that flavorful tip
inside bam that's what it looks like
when it's all done it's like a work of
art ladies and gentlemen it's a work of
art all right go to your local smoke
shop wherever you're at they got King
pom go ask for King pom thank me later
okay King pom local smoke shop 7-Eleven
they got them or you can just go to the
website check this out go to the website
king pom.com take care of somebody in
your life that you love and get 50% off
everything you order at King pom.com
using the promo code bootleg 50% off
that's half off half off King pom.com
you see the
brightness oh thank you for putting the
back on my head you're so polite thank
you thank thank you
[Music]
okay um I wonder man like you know when
we think of like Mount Rushmore of this
rap [__] and like I told you earlier
you've you've kind
of done something that not a lot of
people have done and you've been
extremely
successful in a very shallow
business um without without being you
know kind of sticking to your your
belief sticking to who who you are the
whole time are you kind of like
self-aware to realize that like you are
kind of you are on the Mount Rushmore of
like this hip-hop [__] the last like 10
years like you are like up there you are
the pock of Our Generation for so many
people I never seen them s so it's like
I got a long ways to
go I I don't know I just want to go into
they said and is molded but who's
they the IND IND [__] you know who the
industry is that's the
people I think so many people say it now
whether or not there are people who put
together these end of the year rap lists
and these quote unquote taste makers you
have so many people real people going to
work every day taking care of their kids
every day who say it to me that's the
[__] that matters I be oning a regular
job
sometime like a construction company why
I just sit in the office of days all day
just relax be a regular person yeah so
if you could do any sort of a regular
job it'd have a be having a construction
company could you ever see yourself
like I mean retiring is that even
something you're 24 years old you have I
don't even know how many albums at this
point a lot could you ever see yourself
like does do you have thoughts about
what happens after
rap
I'm kind of set on going to jail right
now so I don't get think about too much
hey you want me to put you over
here when you say you're you're you're
set on going to jail what do you mean
like going back like you think that
that's just in your
fate I guess that is my
life I don't let it bother me on [__]
like that you create the bad
you know you make the bed you lay man so
you that's kind of where your head's at
when you think of the future
still that's that's interesting because
I do think uh shout out to Donnie Brosco
that's on too right now shout out to
alpacino alltime
Goat well I think that you are somebody
who
has an immeasurable amount of influence
and more over power when it comes to
this rap [__] like I had this
conversation uh are you familiar with
the artist name L Russell L Russell he's
from uh Oakland he does concerts in his
backyard independent kid who Okay um but
we were talking about it yesterday and I
was like you know there's a few artists
in this
game Who if they went independent could
break the music industry and really kind
of expose it right and you were one of
those names I think it's you I think
it's Drake I think it's the
weekend who really have the power to
kind of like shift the industry you've
already done it in such a way especially
when it comes to
YouTube but you know you're one of
you're one of them bro you're him bro
like you know I think you you you uh you
definitely have a future outside of of
ending up back in jail hey I real life
hate this [__]
you real life hate this [__] take a toll
on me yeah my my
wife your kids just the music industry
being famous just I wouldn't blame it on
the
industry it's all it's all about how you
go about it and I'm not that
strong that's important to uh be
self-aware about man I cry a lot
literally
I'm in a point I know it's okay like my
like I don't know bro how how much
therapy have you uh tried to go to I
know we talked earlier you g to rehab
but therapy is an important um tool in
anyone's box not just yours but
anybody's box you know to kind of deal
with some I mean not everyone's as
strong as we try to portray ourselves to
be I uh I tried it when I was 18 it was
court order I finished
it um yeah I think the court order
chit's different though you know
like I think you could have you remember
listen we you're Soprano's guy remember
Tony had a
therapist yeah you remember that I
thought that sh was going to get him
killed before before I actually finish
the show for sure but Tony went to
therapy man and it helped him deal with
so much cuz you know I always say this
like for whatever reason men in this
world
we're not allowed
to society doesn't they frown upon us
being hurt they frown upon us having
feelings we're supposed to hold it
together we're supposed to hold down the
kids we're supposed to hold down our
wives we're supposed to pay the bills
and I feel like if you're the head of
your household if you're the head of
your crew if you're the leader who do
you talk to if you're going through some
[__] you know what I'm
saying do you have that person or do you
just internalize it put it out through
the
music
I don't even love music to that point no
more while I run to the
microphone and know I don't got that
person to talk
to I think everybody should find that
person I think you should you should try
to go back to therapy
man because I'm I have it um on this
Saturday oh you do
okay you got to be able to talk to
somebody who doesn't already have kind
of like their mind made up about you or
who can't benefit off you you know what
I'm saying so you can kind of get like a
you can kind of bear your soul to
somebody so
M
ma hey I can smoke a cigarette in
here what you I can smoke a cigarette
right
here I don't know a [__] about
this I'm trying to move in the middle of
the water kid middle of the water mhm
Island
no like you want to be on a
boat yeah nice and the only way you come
to me if the helicopter FL that [__]
and grab you and come back I like that
like lit I want to live on the
water girl I really like this [__] like
man this [__] ain't even my playground
right
like I have my own guess [__] like that
other than that like yeah I don't travel
this house that's crazy man so for you
like cuz for people who don't know you
do you're very secluded where you are um
when you say Gravedigger Mountain like
we're literally there's a mountain you
have a mountain it's your Mountain but
for you
like secluding yourself even more is
interesting just getting a house boat
getting a yacht
hey if you want to see me these are my
coordinates pull up on a helicopter we
ain't
talking I told my wife then last night
she ask me how I eat fish I say fish she
said you can't eat fish all day yeah you
can I said I get I get some food that
shi to me I guess yeah you would have to
somebody would have to boat it to you
but that's not I mean I don't think
that's uh
unrealistic are you are you like um hey
you could tell that I smoke like no no
smoke coming this part I right no I can
tell yeah for sure this the first time
you smoked in this part of the house B
actually when I was looking for the my
clothes looking for this suit earlier
man I walked out the [__] Studio
smoking a cigarette and I had to keep
that door
open how long have you smoked I've been
smoking cigarette since I was 7 years
old damn my dad was like that my dad
tells everybody I've been smoking since
I was eight you want to give this [__]
up my dad got arrested when he was nine
I think my um he tried to burn down his
house my God dead I think he was I think
this [__] ran away from the arm man but
he can't you know how you get a home
pass I guess yeah and that [__]
ran away to New Y New Orleans cuz he
want to go back so I guess during the
time like as he was at the house I used
to be watching that [__] smoking
cigarettes and every time he throw that
[__] I go grab it you grab it you and
you smoke what was left yeah damn yeah I
did that one time my dad threw a
cigarette down I was probably like seven
and I remember I picked that [__] up I
took a hit and I th I was coughing so
much I threw up and my mom was like see
that's what the [__] you get picking up
a [__] cigarette and ever since then
I was I was out on it man I was out on
it I just want to be better than
yesterday it's important man I know and
I I could if I get this same amount of
money and run and go away I would
so for you your in like like it's almost
like if I can get this get to this
certain goal whatever it may be you're
comfortable with just disappearance for
sure for sure once all this behind me
mhm more to Europe or some
[__] once the legal stuff is is out of
your way we might not hear from you all
this put behind me oh you going to hear
from me but we W know where you
are no
I think you always know why I'm meant to
okay is it been it's been what 3 years
now since you've been dealing with the
current situation almost three yeah is
it wearing on you yet man I'm sure at
times it's got to be tough to kind of
just feel confined I mean obviously you
have a nice place but it's still yeah
but I got it better it I got it better
than so many people for sure who are
stuck in their apartment who are stuck
oh oh stuck inside a [__] City going
to the club every
weekend yeah the club man I don't get it
anymore I got every I got I got
everybody to approve
who who I love and who I like to be
around that's important they come on our
car mhm um now I don't wake up in no
sell now you have a beautiful property
man you got beautiful animals you got
beautiful children your wife's here you
got it made man hey we lit could hit
that trail and go all the way behind
this mountain hey we got to stop the
interview real quick man shout out to
our family at my bookie NFL season is
winding down you still got some regular
season uh games you can get in on of
course the college bowl games are coming
up so much money to get plus the cash
prizes going down in their weekly
Blackjack tournaments at
mybookie.ag and uh this is what's going
on right uh my bookie is crazy cuz
they're doing this if you sign up right
now at my bookie use the promo code
bootleg all right claim your deposit
match redeem able up to $1,000 that's
right they're going to match your first
deposit up to
$1,000 using the promo code bootleg
claim your bonus NFL college bowl game
so much going on in terms of what you're
trying to get down with if you want to
gamble if you want to bet all right they
got Blackjack they got roulette they got
it all uh and of course the best odds
anywhere online when it comes to your
sports betting needs so one more time
sign up right now with that promo code
bootleg um and I'm going to tell
everybody this uh you're going to get
your first deposit match up to,
000 I'mma put my money I'm feeling good
about the 49ers future BET right now
slam the ners to win the Super Bowl I
think they're taking that whole [__] bet
anytime anywhere with my bookie also
shout out to our good folks over at
blueo make sure you go over to blue.com
right now a lot of people asking me yo
man blue Chu does that [__] work yeah it
works man find out for yourself though
blue Chu is legit same active ingredient
as viagr seis but if you want to know if
it works they're going to take care of
you with your first month for free by
using the promo code bootleg at blu.com
blu.com use that promo code bootleg and
get your first month for free this is
how goes down no awkward doctor's visits
none of that if you're dealing with a
rectile dysfunction you're dealing with
too much stress maybe you're drinking a
little too much you get the whiskey dick
I don't know H Blu got you all right
blu.com promo code bootleg sign up right
now get your first month supply for free
delivered right to your doorstep for
only $5 in
shipping it's crazy to see like
like the things that like you know your
environment changes you it teaches you
things like for you like do you feel
like you've kind of adopted like being
like an Outdoorsman a bit cuz I feel
like you you got to kind of embrace
nature if you're going to really get
into it like I want to learn how to fill
my backpack up on my own go up in the
mountain start a fire cook something eat
it come back like survive yeah you ever
watch those shows on Netflix where
they're naked and they have to survive
in the middle of nowhere I I I glanced
at them a couple times it's intriguing
cuz you'll see how they start fires you
see how they like they'll catch fish
they'll I mean no that's so so you might
that that might be a nice little side
mission for for you just to kind
of you know hey we're going to go to the
forest for a day we're going to Camp
we're going to we're going to we're
going to catch our
food I had a bobcat jump out on us uh up
there one day a
bobcat what happened
did run off man that [__] that [__]
tried to get to the can now that bit L
tried to run into it it was me and the
dump did it run off did it survive I
even looked to see where it went all we
seen was it cing out the bsh worried
about I be worried about bears bro have
you seen any bears up here no I really
think I saw a big print before so those
bears are the ones cuz they'll come in
the house to look for
food I hope that don't know happen have
you ever watched the that Leonardo
DiCaprio movie Revenant where he gets
attacked by a bear from behind and he
just gets [__] destroyed no it made
me scared of bears forever you know I'm
an animal guy I would I would like to
pet a bear one day you know I'm scared
of a speed yeah ain't no getting away
from this [__] the speed and the force
ain't No Getting Away man man n for sure
dude I just think it's F like a goat cut
I just think it's been dope like
you know to kind of see how you've been
able
to do so much from
here you've done so much since you've
gotten out and since you've been in your
current situation that kind of what make
me second guess a lot though I was
blessed to I was blessed to get a bun
and to be able to be put in this
position for sure so I be saying to
myself like
bro if I do this up you know I'm just
I'm [__]
up you see how they going about me now
so I'm pretty sure if I do anything like
just against
my probation that's my
ass yeah it's pretty interesting man
there they're on top of you for sure
you're definitely
uh and that's got to be that just got to
be
stressful cuz at all times you know
you're kind of under a microscope it
kind of make you it kind of make you do
right
it forces you to to to maybe not make
certain decisions you would have
made do you think it
works yeah do you feel like
um once all this is behind you you're
going
to the same output we're
getting is that something that we're
going to continue to get or you going to
tour the country your fans haven't seen
you live for I don't even know how long
I mean you got to know if you did a tour
right now it's sold out Arenas 52 dates
if if that's even something you would
even want to do you know
mhm is that something you'd be
interested in
doing going and seeing seeing the
fans a year ago I a I ain't want to if I
probably got off house it probably would
have took all the way to this time of
life for me to go on
stage that's
Ste I think that's my cheat code
standing up the
stage I don't disagree with
you a lot of artists they they they
really have they even if they don't want
to go on stage this it's you know this
is kind of how you really make money for
most artists but a lot of artists they
got great ass
music but it ain't going to go if they
don't touch that stage right it ain't
going to go if they not on
tour you have broke that's why I was
when I said earlier like you you really
are you know an enigma when you think of
the music industry because like you said
you you haven't toured like most artists
that
are successful as you are and
uh you do have kind of like I think you
you know you you are you have a lot of
power man you have a lot of influence on
on on this industry period I don't know
a lot of people who were dropping music
the way you drop music until you started
doing it you know it's cuz a lot of
artist mind [__] a lot of a lot of
artists they don't play the game I play
they worry about numbers I ain't never
gave a [__] about no numbers I'm part of
the food chain H raw
material um supplier then the buyer mhm
and that's how all that [__] add up like
that that's how cuz how when a [__]
talk that [__] I can L it whip out a
play got over 100 certifications on that
[__] so you it don't stop there 100 it
don't stop there 100 gold and platinum
records it like it like man it's like
a what place sell food
for alberon Alberton
Ralphs you see all that [__]
meat inside that freezer you know damn
well all of it ain't being bought but I
could guarantee you it's one person
walking in that sto at least buying
something from each category a day yeah
yeah and it's going to add up that's the
game you're playing I can't be [__]
with I don't disagree then hey always
hey numbers don't lie no they do not lie
man and everybody themers been play with
if you pay attention there only no more
than five artists did Big Numbers this
whole year this is true hey and I
guarantee you out of them five three of
them artist numbers was
B I think that a lot of that is starting
to get exposed [__] it I ain't going it
up yeah I think a lot of uh you know the
stream Farms there's a there's an artist
that um you know my boy from the label
who he's working cuz I do radio so he's
he works he's working his record I know
my man a ain't not one thing scripted
about me yeah I ain't got no I ain't got
nobody inside No Label no I ain't got
Jason telling me to go about something
like this no for sure man a [__]
scripted so I
know man man this [__] this [__] so real
this [__] real real life
reality app the real ones are going to
stick with me they going to [__] with me
for sure yeah I think all through my
flaws they going to run with
me and I think you know embracing your
flaws figuring out like kind of
understanding what they are that's the
problem I got with this game today
bro I'm one of them [__] I ain't
always been a standup guy
in every situation or I ain't always
been right that's important to admit man
that's what every [__] man no you're
right though like you know me being here
had I you just reached out to me one day
I don't know what interview you saw mine
but you just had asked me like do you
enjoy what you do and it was randomly
you and I have never
met um and I just hit you like hey dude
I'd love to talk to you one day and you
know we made it happen so I I appreciate
you uh opening up your home to me and um
you know inviting me out to Utah man it
is cold as hell out
here I almost ate [__] on a I wouldn't
call it a snowmobile it's like a snow
scooter um a moon a moon bike whatever a
moon bike that [__] had me [__] up my
legs are really wet right now um for you
man talk about just like you say your
legs wet oh yeah my shit's all the way
up to here I want [__] ass with then
I mean we're we are kind of sitting on a
freshly clean couch riding there hor
yeah and then the couches got clean
that's why we sitting on knes it's damp
for sure we're we're damp right now
we're just in the snow 100% T um I was
going to ask you man like uh somebody
who I think you who was
also very
anti-industry but is also very
successful right now and you have such a
great chemistry and working relationship
you guys got a couple of songs that I
love is
rodwave he is an amazing guy St Pete
which I lived there for a long time
that's somebody who feel a win in the
game
like I think he love what he do he's so
good at it man and I think he's so
positive
and
so taking in a people ain't no way he
could
feel that's real you've been known to do
a collab project here or there would you
guys ever do a whole uh whole tape
together maybe like a little EP or
something I think that'll be a setback
for him
you think so my image [__] up I I
think I got to stay in my own
lane that's fair you guys do got some
great couple great joints together
though he's how often are you like
discovering new artists cuz obviously
you have your crew you have your label
like your artist but are you do you
listen to much other music outside of
your own stuff or your own guys like are
you tapped into like not really I know
about a lot of allti this stuff that I
think the world don't know
about well they I just say they
underground
but I like e you like eat I was saying
like they like eat okay I don't think he
underground no more he was but he's not
now yeah and I think it's a lot of more
artists like that that's to come yeah
there's like guys like destroy lonely
and ye and yeah lonely hard yeah know um
yeah I feel like there's a difference
between being like underground because
you're not necessarily commercial but I
think once you get to the point where
you get in a billion streams I don't
know how underground you could be you
know cuz I think some people still
consider you who are like just generic
music
fans they might think that you're kind
of like underground but you're not
you're one of the biggest artist in the
world you know what I mean so that's
because they live in a different
world that's true they not into they not
into nothing and like
me I mean you are one1 man I'll say that
I don't think there's any denying
that does it matter to you the the cuz
you said
earlier when the industry says you or
that does does the recognition of the
quote unquote industry from where you're
at right now does it even matter at all
even if it's at 1% I'm paid I don't give
a [__] and that's all I want to
be I told you you got to learn when the
jokes is on you we a we ain't nothing
but
entertainment and at the end of the day
we're the most lowest people on Earth
cuz we got an image to keep up it's hard
to be yourself it it's hard to be
yourself man you know me [__] be want
to come across that [__] and talk crazy
about a woman but but but won't because
they know that [__] tear that image down
and a lot of people don't like that so
they not going to speak they man and
it's a whole lot of different situations
like like that's different than that
they be eating people
up but they got this [__] down pack they
ain't going to let nothing play with
their image I
guess yeah I think a lot of people get
caught up in their image I think a lot
of people get caught up in their social
media AES static how they look online
it's like at the end of the day if you
could just unapologetically be yourself
at all
times it it should work out for you you
know what I'm saying what turn out bad I
mean it could turn out bad I mean like
they so tired they get to start starting
to feel like oh he really a piece of
[__] but this [__] ain't got no no type
of moral morals or
sympathy but then again they just don't
know like you probably one of
the most South heartest hearted people
walking the Earth
one of the most giv
ever but all that [__] don't matter when
they opinion come
about I think Society does a really bad
job at judging people because mostly we
judge people off their worst moments I'm
against Society think about it like I'm
just I just know today like hurting
people ain't the way they hurt to hurt
somebody right yeah but I don't a [__]
about that n i mean listen I think I
think people like to judge people off of
their low points in life you might have
a one bad night make one bad decision
but I'm man I swear I if I had if it was
anything to show you I want you to see
all my low points in life no you very
transparent I wouldn't want you to see
[__]
right uh you mentioned you went to rehab
recently um is that something that has
you found
helpful yeah I really I really needed it
t and I met some very cool
people and I was accepted in a way I
never was
before so I love I love I love that
place was it in like a 12-step meeting
did you do a like a 12-step meeting like
a where you like everyone sits down
everyone shares their thoughts I've been
I've been in some meetings before they I
think they cleared the house out for me
as I arrived just to let me check it out
yeah it's important man I think uh you
know to be self-aware enough to know hey
I got to go I got to go see somebody
it's
important I love being
high I think everyone loves being high
it's just what comes after that yeah
it's just this not the time right it's
not the time at all yeah I love being
high as well and drunk and all of that
stuff I've been in my own personal you
know situations with especially with
alcohol man alcohol is a [__]
bro cuz you you you'll having the best
night of your life and it goes left like
that tell me about it man have you
[__] up now you go to got to go to
court I like I love to pop that [__]
when I'm when I'm drunk yeah I you start
drinking you start pop that [__] when
you like like [__] I to tell you about
yourself oh [__] it would you say like
uh you know every everybody's
complicated but a lot of times when we
see you online right you and and you're
popping your [__] is it Mo like let's
say not necessarily recently but would
you be like drinking at the time most of
the time or no that's 100% me I mean
listen alcohol brings out the truth no
no I'm talking about I be sober okay
that's 100% me I I RAR let them catch
me that's real n for real for real that
100%
me [__] you that's how I'm really
feeling I love you that's really
genuine who are somebody uh you know
you've had some big homies in the rap
game obviously
bman Uh Kevin Gates go on and on shout
out to Gates who are some people who
consistently check in on you and your
well-being that aren't necessarily
trying to get a feature aren't trying to
you know get something from you is there
anybody at in the music industry who who
I don't really talk to nobody but
I stun most of the time I can tell boy I
can tell you about these [__]
though you get your soul hurt you get
your soul hurt meeting
somebody and finding out that that ain't
it ain't it ain't who you think they are
n [__]
no then a [__] a [__] a [__] a [__]
get the Mad [__] get mad how thorough you
[__] n speaking on on you like like
like like like like you ain't like you
ain't who you say you is or
something so birman's been pretty
consistent you know making sure he
that's the five yeah Al Legend obviously
I'm sure you learned a lot from him and
you know he with anything I'm on
L shout out to
Birdman how's the uh I know you just
dropped an album you just dropped
another
single um with your current situation
and I know you got like a one of one
type of
situation um how long is is is is your
deal with with with mtown
capital cuz you could burn through a I
feel like you could burn through a
record contract in like three months if
you if you really wanted to like a
traditional one obviously but that's the
problem that's the problem like
I'm I'm I'm caught up right now like
you're you're free to do whatever you
want obviously yeah but I ain't trying
to give all the [__] free
cuz now I see they ain't trying to take
care of me so everything got to be
counting for or drop
me and let me show you some
[__] would you ever consider going fully
independent with with building
infrastructure and a team out where you
can just say I'mma do me my life ain't
set up that way I'm down for it though I
can't I ain't going to
fail but
[__] like one day man maybe maybe not
currently hopefully one day but I want I
I want that money
man I mean Mone is important man yeah I
mean that's why we do what we do right
sometimes that's the only thing and in
some situations that that's the only
thing that got your back the money your
money that's some real
[Music]
[__] well listen man I appreciate you
you having me out I appreciate you for
coming bro I had a great time here bro I
think we were supposed to make a song
but we'll do it another time I guess
right um I look forward to uh to just
seeing the rest I mean look 2024 is
coming I know you're going to have a big
year
um I just appreciate the hospitality man
I know you don't do a lot of these so
it's a big deal you know for me to be up
here to me so thank you and um I just
man for sure bro it it was a fun time
come back any time without the camera
yeah for sure I'll come back with the
camera may bring my kid with me you know
what I'm saying we hop on the horse
that's hard for sure go slay riding with
the dogs the slay riding that sounds fun
that's what I'm trying to put together
right now for my video let me know I'll
pull up man I to bring the kid No
cameras we'll just have
fun bring the great D trucks I got a lot
of RC cars yeah you got the camm and
everything yeah no no for sure and I'm
going I'm going to bring an actual
Gravedigger truck a monster truck it's a
monster truck you know that right my
dream is to um turn a Ros R truck into a
great [__] oh that' be [__] crazy I
mean I'm sure you could just make that
happen tomorrow if you want you just got
to find the guy to do it you know yeah I
appreciate you man stay safe um and uh
you know I I I'm I I love to see your
growth man you know I think that's
something that i' I've publicly said in
interviews like I just love to see when
people are self wear and they grow
because who we are yesterday and who we
are today and who we're going to be
tomorrow is not who we are today so much
love bro appreciate you man for sure man
thank you young boy F can we show some
love to our family at harden man shout
out to hardine man look if you're in
Vegas you got to pull up you got to say
take me to harden right now I need to go
to harden they're going to take you
they're going to get you situated Harden
Las Vegas the best cannabis uh
dispensary I've ever walked into in my
life the most craziest selection a
premium cannabis in the entire world I
mean that place smells like
God's uh sweat it feels it just smells
so good in there it's just oh they got
their own scent they're our family too
man so make sure you follow them online
Hardin Las Vegas all right shoot them a
follow on uh Instagram also go to Hardin
Las vegas.com and when you're in Vegas
make sure you pull up to harden baby